Jason Mewes is taking the spotlight
again in 2019 with Jay and Silent Bob
reboot as well as this directorial debut
madness and Method but it hasn't always
been light-hearted fun in the life of
this actor filmmaker and podcaster his
rise at fall and rise again is a
remarkable story and he was kind enough
to tell us about it
well muse cracked audiences up with his
drug-related antics in the movies of
hometown friend Kevin Smith
he spent what should have been the best
years of his career falling increasingly
into addiction even as he shined on
screen substance abuse was quietly
causing damage in his life endangering
his safety and derail eNOS career
fortunately muse was able to turn the
tables on his addictions in the early
2000s starting a process of sober living
that has continued to this day
according to Smith the Silent Bob two
muses Jay Mewes was born the son of a
heroin abuser and spent most of his
childhood raised by an aunt while his
mother fed her Jones or spent years in
jail despite this Muse was essentially
living a straightedge lifestyle when
Smith first met him priya booze drugs
and even romance things can change
pretty fast when you're a teenager
though and when the time came to shoot
clerks Hughes had morphed into an
enthusiastic drinker and pot smoker and
essentially played himself in the movie
here is a dude who was just like I don't
know if I could say these things imma do
you do say these things hey smoking
Claire and how many times have I told
you not to be dealing in front of the
store I'm not talking about
and all cheer Oh but while the scumbag
lifestyle came off is funny on screen
the real life Muse was on a dangerous
path the success of clerks left Muse
living a kind of dual life he had a foot
in the film industry but was it making
or saving a ton of money when filming
wrapped he'd go back to working regular
jobs it came home from our ancestor
delivering pizza and putting doing
construction with my buddy
and then I had to chasing him you know I
went back to the delivering pizza and
putting in doing construction so I
worked at a regular job for years it
really was until after Dogma that I
stopped working construction and
delivering pizza but his muses star
continued to rise his drug use was
becoming more problematic especially as
he shifted away from weed and beers
toward more addictive substances heroin
cocaine and even crack when news began
shooting heroin Smith began working to
get news off the opiates he gave him
rides to methadone clinics where the
recognisable duo drew stares as Smith
would later put it stoners are cute
junkies are sad he thinks just cuz you
don't say anything it'll have some huge
impact and it does open this disgrace
won't you shut up Muse is clear that it
wasn't Hollywood pressure that made him
dip further into using drugs I think I
started using drugs in Jersey it's like
it definitely isn't a Hollywood thing it
definitely isn't a movie thing or
anything I mean I definitely I
definitely feel like I've started
drinking if anything more but that was
more just because I wanted to like go
out and there's lots of fun clubs as
Muse put it in the film industry opiates
and heroin and painkillers and stuff is
taboo which allowed Muse to keep the
extent of his drug use private on screen
he was serving up the goods and if he
was falling asleep on set in the middle
of takes while shooting Dogma Wow
audiences didn't notice you can't just
go around breaking people's hearts like
that I've know not what you we fell in
love with you guys I guess just a father
sky you know according to Kevin Smith
muses drug usage had reached dangerous
friendship testing levels by the time
Dogma wrapped on top of nodding off on
SATs he was acquiring track marks and
damaging his teeth he once reportedly
rolled his truck through a traffic stop
while under the influence colliding with
the car of an off-duty police officer he
was arrested for heroin possession in
New Jersey after being stopped by police
driving around with a deployed airbag an
incident which was later used for yuxun
a scene in clerks two tribe now it
deployed airbag after Dogma
circumstances what occasionally compel
them used to check into rehab programs
leaving him off drugs for brief periods
of time but the drugs remained a
fixation to the point where his next
movie almost didn't happen
during the pre-production of Jay and
Silent Bob strike back a blow-up between
Muse and Smith nearly resulted in the
movie being cancelled in pre-production
as Kevin Smith tells the story it would
be better to cut their losses than risk
having Muse fall off the wagon while the
movie was being shot the director
recalls that he told Muse you can do all
the dope you want now because we're
stopping the movie for fans of the
stoner duo the whole episode is a
bracing dose of reality while the movie
may have been light-hearted why they
call you knocker actually there's a
funny story behind that you're gonna
love this true story
the backdrop of its production was not
according to Smith news stayed clean
during shooting but was back to using
opiates within hours after shooting his
last scene during the months of
post-production while Smith was busy
finishing the movie his on-screen
partner reportedly lost 30 pounds as a
result of smoking crack after resuming
his drug usage Muse was caught having
heroin mailed to a hotel during a strike
back press junket and was also caught
stealing money from Smith in New Jersey
a warrant was issued for his arrest
after he failed to show up for a court
date violating the probation he was on
after his previous arrest all of these
factors led Smith to decide against
casting news in his sixth film Jersey
girl which was mostly shot around their
hometown of Highlands New Jersey shut
out a production and knowing he'd be
arrested if he ever returned home Muse
decided to base his problems head-on and
surrender muses returned in New Jersey
to face the authorities was accompanied
by an all-time indicator of a man living
on the edge a short-lived rumor that he
had died instead of being locked away
immediately Muse was given a choice a
year in jail or six months of rehab he
chose rehab I wasn't like I stepped away
from everything to be like hey I need to
clear my head from being in that
Hollywood spotlight or the on the town
or something it was literally just like
hey I need to try to take care of this
problem I have and I don't know how to
do it besides going to turn myself into
the to the New Jersey court systems or
what have you and just try and like and
I just sort of fell off the mat it turns
out falling off the map was exactly the
thing he needed to turn things around
more than four years into muses efforts
at going sober he fell victim to a
common pitfall feared by many recovering
heroin users legally prescribed opiates
it's not even like I went out and like
chase did I I had gotten hurt and I got
a shot of Demerol for the pain and that
sort of sparked the whole thing back I
go I remember that feeling and I miss it
I relapsed again and Kevin was like you
were doing so well yet for years over
four years what happened I wasn't
accountable to anybody or talk name was
news realized he needed to be
accountable to something more than just
himself talking to Smith about his
struggles the idea came up to
essentially keep the conversation
indefinitely and invite the public to
listen in well I wanted to do a podcast
and I was like what he's like what do
you want to do the podcast about I said
I don't know and he's like well why
don't we talk about what you're thinking
every day and this way you're
accountable to people who are listening
and watching the ensuing podcast Jay and
Silent Bob get old went on to produce
over 200 episodes
according to Muse the show is over at
least for now giving way to the
obligations of the taurine reboot
Roadshow as well as muses own twitch
channel yes baby from use the podcast
was a constant reminder of the
commitment he'd made to sobriety and a
way to connect with bands all around the
world going through the same struggles
much like the movie sees most famous for
it was an experience that brought
moments both profane and surprisingly
profound
oh what a thunk that we literally went
like seven years and we toured Australia
in London and all that stuff and that
was Jay and saw Bob get old outside of
the podcast and keeping busy with work
Muse says he's making his continuing
sobriety work with the help of a caring
support system which includes his family
and friends who aren't shy about keeping
him accountable
a friend who's a kay man you've been
sober two years and you're really
addicted to to drugs not booze you can
have a beer univ one beer like that to
me isn't like again he might be afraid
it might be a friend but not really so
that to me was a big deal surrounding
myself with people who knew like no I
can't have a beer because then I'll be
smoking crack in a month and and yeah
I'll disappear whatever he's doing that
seems to be working and he's been sober
for more than nine years you know
sometimes I wish I'd did a little more
of my life instead of hanging out in
front of places selling weed on top of
closing out 2019 by touring with the
reboot Roadshow
news also celebrated a major milestone
in his career directing his first movie
the film madness and the method was
released in theaters and on demand in
August 2000 nineteen the premise of the
movie revolves around a world much like
the real one with Muse playing a twisted
version of himself
everyone plays themselves but like a
multiverse version of themselves the
movie follows Jay as he attempts to
break out of the more stoner style roles
he's had a tendency to be typecast
then less true-to-life is how he
accomplishes this goal following the
unorthodox advice from a mysterious book
on method acting to unexpectedly
effective results stepping into the role
of director didn't just fulfill a
lifetime goal from use it also
demonstrated just how many of his peers
in the film industry have come to care
about him over his long and charmed
career it was really nice because when
we reached out to Dean K and teri
hatcher Jaime Camil everyone like hey
listen we don't have a lot of money but
but Jaime's is directing his first movie
is there anyway and they were they came
and and and was part of the movie
because they're like we want to be part
of that if he's gonna be directing for
the first time we want to be part of his
directing debut so that was really
really nice check out one of our newest
videos right here lost even more looper
videos about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]